hello
i think we're good
hi funny how are you man
hi hi hi
i believe we're live at least i hope we
are
yes
[Music]
game is working
let's get it
how are you today funny
i'm good too dude
very good
bam bam
oh yeah i was making a thumbnail
give me my hud back and my weapons
i had
you
and i had
you
okay
i think we're good
[Music]
what the hell
do not need that
okay so i thought today
we would explore
caleb
as much as we want
would be the main area we look at today
because this area is kind of gross
so i didn't really stick around in it
very much
didn't explore
trade again okay i've been here
oh yeah
we already checked you out
bam
yeah see like those those big ass birds
right there
not a fan of the birds
the birds scare me
is it even on a branch
oops
this is what i wanted to do
yeah
it's on a branch
hi evan
all right come on come at me bird
what the
ow
so i can't even tell what it's doing oh
god
okay it's not that hard to kill
well not right now obviously
jesus christ
that bird is too big
to be safe to be around
well yeah this entire area is infected
with scarlet rot yeah i think it's a a
crow then we have these guys
dino dogs
gross
i even use this yet no i need to get
more intelligence
if possible
it is very bloodborney
all of caled is very bloodborney
like the
very saturated red
sky
very bloodborne-esque
what's this guy eating
whoops i didn't even want to use this
see this this is where i think like uh
oh he was eating another dog
ow
how how do you hit bugs in this game
how look at that
there we go jesus christ
yeah this one died a while ago
nasty
nasty
i don't like that nasty
this is where i think this game is all
just like a dream sequence
you know i mean
like
this right here is just like nightmare
fuel for me
you know what i mean it's a it's a
nightmare or something it's not real
but then you know the scarlet the
scarlet rot could do this technically
i'm not as strong as
rig
strong as hell
dog eat dog
yeah
isn't that church up here
and really look
yeah
yeah you get what i mean when i say that
i guess i haven't been up here
because i'm never gonna like make a
video on this or not i wouldn't never
say never but
like i'm holding off on making a video
about how i think all of elden ring is
just a dream
because that is my theory i'm i'm
holding to it but i just don't have
enough
to like explain that you know what i
mean
i need more
evidence
it feels like a dream
to me
so i can't use any of that
i do need to make a build that's all
about
like the dragon
you know like arcane faith build
actually probably be really fun
yeah
what i have learned over the past month
of making elden ring content is like if
you don't provide evidence people will
[ __ ] on your video really hard so
i don't want to just be like
this is what i think
and then people go like here's why
you're wrong i don't really want that
so
we'll see
i'm making a video right now on the
round table actually
or i'm writing a script for it
should be out in a couple days
maybe probably by tomorrow
we'll see
okay i guess we can just go down here
you know what let's go to
let's go over there let's go to um what
what's it what's it called
celia
this is where apparently radon
learned all of his uh sorceries
in this like town over here apparently
i'm gonna kill that giant first though
[Music]
austin thank you for the five dollar
super chat
this is a fun series to watch thank you
for bringing it to us be sure to
interpret as vaguely as possible so you
don't upset a few haters that's the plan
man
i am i'm being very uh
careful with my words
i appreciate that man that's my first
ever super chat thank you austin
thank
you
by the way i i didn't mention this at
the beginning but we unlocked all the
stuff like we have memberships now
we have super chats we've got we've got
everything so
we worked it all out with youtube and
it's looking good so thank you again
austin
very kind
and yeah i'll be
i have to be vague
can't say anything is uh
you know
set in stone in this game i was gonna go
kill the giant then i didn't go up here
i don't think i can get up there
is that a pot
he's throwing pot boys at us
i think i have to get up there over here
and i'm glad you enjoy it
i like making it it's fun
what is this
stop by the shack i wonder why they put
that here because that's a universal
message
[Music]
who doesn't like my content
the giant
this guy's so sus
what
kind of scars you got on your face bro
he's got freckles
weird
hold on
okay there we go
he's got freckles
he's got
you have burns on his hands
no
i don't know
sus
a pleasure to see you a pleasure indeed
i am thank you dan a great sage
in my day i'm glad you like it dude
and thank you for subbing
when one of your ilk came along
a strapping young tarnished
don't fret i'll provide fine recompense
should you accept oh yeah we gotta go
kill the general and get the the needle
then you are willing to lend a hand are
you
sure i need your help to heal a certain
young girl
maleficent right
i think millicent not maleficent
we'll have to explore all of celia i've
never done that
okay i know what to do
wait i should get all your dialogue
he turns into a pest when killed
innocent suffering can be ameliorated
we can check that you want to find a
certain can i kill him once cause i
think he comes back right
like you can't really kill him
the needle made from unalloyed gold is
lost somewhere there
okay
let's give it a shot
you and i
there are countless pests to choose
from hmm
that is weird
damn
but i think if i rest and come back he's
here again
anything weird about him no he just
looks just like
are these called pests
i mean they are [ __ ] annoying
i think he comes back if not
we can go to the church of vows
get him back
ain't too worried about it
let's check out uh let's check out the
town let's give it a shot
yeah i don't i don't know why he turns
into that that is a good question
oh i made a noise
oh hey i can use my uh
shield here
for science
exactly
hello sir
you see how these guys are
glowing didn't think he'd do that
does that mean they're not actually here
or is that just what like the uh
invisibility spell makes them look like
stop
oh calm down my man
and we're one shot in everything now
so somebody had a really cool theory
a couple days ago on stream
so you guys know these paintings that
are
spread out all over the game right
if you play dark souls 3 you know that
paintings are really important like in
the dlc where the the girl
um
she creates the world right by with her
paintings
someone was like what if
the lands between is just one of her
paintings
and i was like
that is a sick theory
with no evidence besides
the paintings to back that one up
but i don't think that can ever be
completely dismissed
sir
oh my god
oh
i have not seen that spell before
it's kind of cool
okay it looks like i killed the group
and i got my blue flask back that's
that's nice
it's over here
i just see a guy yup hello
ow
i don't even know there was a door here
we'll have to hit all the um the bells
up top or the lights whatever they're
called
sir
you're gone
why are you running away oh i understand
the strongest enemy
in the game
a dog
eat you
i'm gonna die
the strongest enemy in the game
when you get the painting theory to body
stat
you know i think vadi will act like
there's no way he doesn't think that
there's no way seeing all these
paintings that's another thing we have
to do is try and find all of the uh
all of these
because apparently cool stuff happens
when you like go to the exact spot
of some of these paintings
yeah i got i got [ __ ] up by that dog
goddamn
we'll have to do that but i i man
i thought i would find it really weird
if lottie didn't think that
because they would say yeah elden rings
a completely different world
it
it could still be
connected
in a way
you know
technically
okay now that guy's dead i am killing
you immediately sir
killing you
die
there it is here's what happens when you
don't get backed in a corner
oh my god
get some help buddy
there we go
it's a very interesting theory
another video that i want to make but
need more uh
i guess i could make it and just say
like whatever man [ __ ] it
let let people get mad let them debate
why not
right who who really cares
a meet yep exactly immediately debunks
it
right it's the same universe
but not the exact same
you know
yeah
i think it's a very interesting theory
that i think
would make a lot of comments
comments are fun
i wonder if they fix that glitch to get
up there
believe that
that one opens the main door to
millicent
i think
dude every time guys
every time i start stream i i just have
to burp
i never
i i literally never burp i haven't eaten
anything today yet
or yes i have
it's cause i'm talking
it is buzzworthy
i think it's worth
the debate
because it it makes sense like i haven't
really seen anybody talk about the
paintings in elden ring yet they're just
like there and they're like oh fun it's
like
well why are they there who who is this
artist
whose shack is this you know i haven't
seen anybody talk about that yet
a lot of controversy hell yeah dude get
people talking
screw it
you
know yeah
i don't know which one i opened up
oh god
god i haven't killed these guys yet did
i open this one
no
rig dude
it's cole
hi buddy
no
you look better than a painting in elden
ring
no you sir
we gotta stir the pot sometimes
i don't think anything's wrong with that
i'll take the hit with the comments
that's fine
where are these [ __ ] going
hello
spray me with your spells
now
hmm
did i even interact with this painting
no it did not
yes cole controversy
we're making the theory that these
paintings you haven't played dark souls
3 i don't think but um
basically the entire world of dark souls
is
is made through
one girl who
in her paintings right
there's a lot of paintings in elden ring
so
my our theory someone in chat said it a
couple days ago
that
we're just the lands between is just one
of her paintings
it's like i kinda i kinda like that
screw you my spells can find you
ha
haha
oh how fast you can cast that
or my shield
okay i guess i killed that guy or he
walked down here
but yeah apparently this town is where
radon studied his uh sorceries and stuff
which seems quite small
for
the size of radon
that could be the case the thing is is
that there's not a lot of evidence
leading to that like whatsoever so i
just know that if i did make a video on
it all the comments would just be like
no you're wrong and then they'd write
like four paragraphs as to why i'm wrong
and like a link to an article of
miyazaki saying like no there's no
no correlation
and then people would comment to that
comment saying uh why they're wrong with
10 paragraphs
and i'm i'm just over here like
thanks for the comments
it pushes the algorithm
thank you very much okay let's go up top
again
but it very well could be the case
and it very well
could be completely [ __ ] wrong
maybe radon was much younger
eventually
because radon would like
tower over these buildings
it would make sense because like he he
even learned uh gravity spells to not
crush his uh
his horse anymore
you're totally wrong did you see
teriyaki fingers latest video
obviously land between is made by lego
exactly
obviously you're wrong
i don't know why but i got i got in it
with someone last night uh
in my
most recent video in the comments where
he was like it's bad game design that uh
people are missing the
tutorial where
i was just like man you are a [ __ ]
wimp
hi trey
like yeah they they made the tutorial in
a cave
uh that you have to drop down into that
i thought would kill me
i'm like it's not that deep like it's
like it's literally not that deep of a
hole man like just drop down it's like
well i still missed it it took me 12 and
a half hours to to find the tutorial i'm
like there's a glowing man in a chair
and a mess a universal message on the
ground that says cave of knowledge lies
below
and most like i've seen tons of people
just walk right past it
it's like okay
i would like to know the where toriel is
but i will do two seconds of research on
the game before diving in
yes
yeah that's always a suggestion
he took 12 and a half hours behind the
tutorial meaning he ran right past it
came back and then found it and he's
like what the heck dude
why is this here man
so funny
okay is that all of them
let me check this one
oh it just leads to a chest
okay what do we got here
whoa
a blue key that's rare as [ __ ]
we can use that at the 12 belfries
they're the four belfries the [ __ ]
12.
we got the main door open i think
there's another one
hold on i have to kill this man
yeah i mean
i said i said it in the video
there are people in video games who have
no idea what to do
when they aren't having their
like they need to have their hand held
the entire time or they just like get
frustrated and give up because they
don't know exactly what to do
like um
you know they don't have a quest log
they don't have
um like a thing on them like the compass
at the top like with indicators telling
them exactly where to go
um
none of that so they get frustrated with
this game
and then they call it like bad or bad
game design because it doesn't tell you
where to go
and it's like
in my opinion that shit's been outdated
for so [ __ ] long
like uh
you know
rockstar telling you
everything you need to do
checkpoint to checkpoint just like
boring driving
to a spot that it's telling you to go to
progress it's like
just let me roam around on my own
and this game does that like so well
i actually don't know what other door i
opened do these guys respawn so many of
them
i get how people miss it i mean yeah
that's the point
the game uh
the game rewards discovery
risk taking
um
oh it must have been this one
it rewards exploration
the knight comet what is that that
sounds cool
and they tell you that right off the bat
with them not showing you
you know exactly like where the tutorial
is exactly i mean it is right there
you gotta explore
you know with maybe five seconds of
effort the guy even said like it
shouldn't be require any effort to go
through a tutorial and i'm like
what effort it's right there
you have to read what like he even said
like if i have to read something that
tells me to go to tutorial that's just
bad game design i'm like
shut the [ __ ] like what a wimp man in my
opinion
one of the night sorceries of celia town
of sorcery fires a semi-invisible magic
comet
can be cast repeatedly while in motion
charging enhance potency selling
sorcerers were assassins and it was said
that they often hunted their fellows
like fellow sorcerers cool
i slayed it
some gamers are task oriented i am one
of those people i like to have a quest
log at least very early in the game but
i love free world games like skyrim
where you can roam and encounter things
to do
yeah skyrim has like both right like you
have your quest log
but it doesn't tell you exactly how to
do it you still have to explore
and like figure it out on your own which
i can appreciate that
for me like my personality is so like do
not tell me what to do if you tell me
what to do like [ __ ] off like i hate i
hate games that do that man
this game doesn't tell me what to do at
all and i appreciate it
yeah this town just seems like [ __ ]
destroyed dude
like not a lot
going on here is this an openable door
no
assassin's creed odyssey has so many
markers on the map it's overwhelming
whenever i think of that i think of far
cry like i don't know why but every far
cry game there's just like
go to this little outpost and destroy
you know the radar at the top or the
radar tower and you do that like 20
[ __ ] times until it's like you
destroyed all of the water or the
all the towers in this area
achievement unlocked i'm like
it's so boring to me
other people it's not boring though so
it's just me
it's just
me this game always the same
overwhelming feeling but having almost
nothing on the map
i mean i i like that
i mean
you can't be immediately overwhelmed
because like this is new game plus four
you don't have all the map so you don't
really know what to be overwhelmed by
unless you just keep progressing like if
this map was just here
and i didn't know how big the world is
right off the rip i would be probably
overwhelmed but they kind of like slowly
show it to you
which i think helps but there's not like
markers
on on where to go
oh hello
oh i not found her yet
it's pretty old way of gaming
where you had to figure stuff out so i
can see the argument but if you're
taking 12 hours maybe those games aren't
for you
that that's what i wound up saying to
the guys like maybe these games just are
not for you and that's fine
that's totally fine
but
like with that in my opinion
i feel like gaming
has been such a
a hand holding
like all the games that come out are so
hand-holdy tell you exactly what to do
like
like walk forward to this spot that's
glowing on the ground
it's like
i [ __ ] hate that
it's like i i know how to walk bro like
this game respects you that that you're
not like stupid
which i can appreciate
hi fluffy
i'm good man
good to see you
i think we found everything
at least in the town
blah
we can go
we should get the needle right
let's go do that
what are these guys doing here
oh nope
not not dealing about not dealing with
that
had no idea about the switch till today
um
i mean you don't pay attention to
announcements then that's the case
if you're not on the discord then
you wouldn't know i suppose
this guy's beefy
now
did he get staggered i think so
[Music]
ow
i'm gonna mimic it up
try to at least
[Music]
did my mimic just not work yep
owie
god his his attacks are so [ __ ]
delayed
i am too close
to the outside here
okay i got the i got the freeze off
that was awesome
nice
i remember spending like three hours on
that
the first time i did it
because i was so underleveled
no i am but like i saw it late okay
well now you know
my friend played this game completely
differently than i did looked up every
single detail so he was
progressing
i just can't play that way but respect
how he chose to experience it
perfect like
you can play this game however the [ __ ]
you want and they give you like all of
the means to do so
because you can have those different
experiences like you said
the people that are like you're not
playing it with like no armor rune level
one
just melee like you're like they'll say
like you're an intelligence build so
you're having an easier time and you're
not having a good experience in the game
it's like where the it's not your
[ __ ] playthrough
there's so many people that say that and
i'm just like you're so dumb like shut
up
everyone can have their own like
experience in a video game it's
yeah let's gate keep how people play a
single player game
so weird dude
oh we should actually check if this
guy's even alive
dab
i hate those basic tutorials too
the devs are trying to help those people
who rarely ever play games
uh it's a nuisance for us to push
through but a deal breaker for a newbie
that's true
you do have to think of everybody
see he's alive
we killed this guy and he came back as
promised i've detailed the secret of
celia right here
go on
it's yours
what does this even say
[Music]
for one of the hardest known games
yeah and those elitists will say like
elden rings not a true experience it's
not hard
it's the easiest souls game
like
you know it like
people suck man
they really do
people suck as well made as it is
snapped in half
oh yeah he i think if i rest and come
back like he's
literally done
literally
oh
there's got to be some explanations oh
we're going to find out
we're gonna find out
right now
we're gonna get we're gonna go to
millicent real quick though
new splash don't remember asking
right
it
i here here's what i found out
in because i actually i should have
thought this more recent like
earlier on but i've figured this out
more more recently is that
most people who comment on how somebody
should be playing something or just com
almost honestly comment in general
they're
just looking i'm gonna die holy [ __ ]
who is this
they are looking to start [ __ ] that's
all that's their entire goal is to start
some [ __ ]
and that's it
so it's not even worth your time to say
anything to some of these people bro
like
again the greatest feature
i've ever seen is youtube's feature to
hide somebody from a channel
where they have no idea
you're basically
shadow banning something without them
knowing
so they can still leave their [ __ ]
comment and nobody will see it not a
single person
so we don't have to ban them we don't
got to deal with uh
you know
an unban appeal
give them any more time of day
yep they win if they get a reaction
that's exactly right
okay
uh no you're cute kyle
man i need to like
i need to talk more off stream so i
don't like have uh
burping sessions while i'm streaming
i'm not doing the speed run so i can
just like kill these guys
do you think that these guys are
guarding millicent because like when you
kill that guy we just talked to
that wants the needle or that we gave
the needle to he's actually one of these
guys
and they're guarding millicent who's in
here
good
could be
millicent
how we doing over here
that is the royal great sword
it matters not
if you are wise you will leave
immediately
my flesh writhes with scarlet rot
yes
not to be meddled with by man
another thing
i know she's a part of melania's
um questline
but it is so weird to me
red hair one arm
she looks she has no arm same arm as
melania
just weird
af
we'll have to look deeper into that
much deeper
um i need more int
so
i'm not really looking to level anymore
but uh yeah
okay let's go back
i don't even know where we were at
oh he's right here
whatever i can just ride there
out of the way
um
oh this is where i can go to kill the
giant
foggers
a lesser
kindred of rot
interesting many hours you have
like 2
20 to 10
i think i'm gonna die but let's i'm
nope we're good
oh god
oh god all right we're fine
gallery
the needle is repaired
now it will forestall the rotting
sickness i'm
we need to read it before we give it to
here
thought she was melania
no no no no
no
is it i think she is her sister i i
somebody wrote something about it and i
just was like i'm not sure
we're gonna read what that is first
though maybe it'll teach us more about
gallery there
but no this is not melania
she does have one arm though
infected with scarlet rot red hair
but no
let's see
is it a key item
yes
an intricately crafted needle of
unalloyed gold once snapped in half has
been repaired by the sage gallery a
ritual implement
crafted to ward away the meddling of
outer gods
it is thought capable of forestalling
the incurable rotting sickness
now all you need is delivered to the
needle to maleficent church to top the
clip of celia
she's a painting from dark souls 3 who
is
who if you are wise you will leave
immediately
my flesh writhes with scarlet rot
millicent
give golden needle
i didn't say that
but you can do it with it however you
want
never mind
i've decided
i would rather trust you
than simply continue to spoil from
within
would you mind
averting your eyes for a moment
oh she's sticking herself like right in
the chest the [ __ ]
hello
well
that was easier than expected
you good
just kills over and dies
oh yeah she's out
were all these lit up before these
flowers
i might be stretching here
he does have the same
head and shape hat as the pests well we
know that he's one of them
we know that
like we we killed him and he turned into
one of them
could just be like he's taking over
their body
which is clearly very possible
whoops did not want to do that
another thing i want to test is uh
you guys know in dark souls 3 when you
stand in front of the fire keeper and
you do emotes sometimes she'll react to
the emote
i haven't really tested any of that on
npcs in this game but they don't seem to
react to any emotes not not really any
of them
like you would do like a heartening cry
in front of the fire keeper and she
would like laugh or something
haven't found much
but there could be some i
hoped to see you again i mean it's been
like five seconds
i fainted before i could even thank you
everything is as you said
since inserting the needle the scarlet
rot has ceased to rise
even the nightmares have abated
and now
though i can scarcely believe it myself
i can move as i please
not that i could ever truly repay you
but
i would like you to have this
by way of thanks
a token though it is
whoa that's my dyslexia is gonna hit
hard here
pro pro thesis where
heirloom
what is that
talisman
oh it raises dex
that makes sense
talisman engraved at the scene from a
heroic tale raises dexterity
heroic tale
though born into the curse rot when the
young girl encountered her mentor and
his flowing blade she gained wings of
unparalleled strength
when a young girl encountered her mentor
and his flowing blade
is she talk is that referring to um
this
hold on
the mirai executioner sword
and i believe his name is ed edgar edgar
something like that flowing blade
because they have a connection
they
i'm not sure the connection
man
that would make sense right
not entirely sure
i'm considering leaving
on a journey
with the needle buried in my flesh
so that would mean that he was
my destiny melania's teacher thanks to
you
my name
pray fate is us meet again
it could be true
i'm considering leaving
with the needle my destiny
my destiny
augurs hello the [ __ ]
damn i am stronk
i don't really need that anymore but uh
let's go back to the shack
i wonder if she leaves here
gone
did she leave anything
nope
let's go back to the shack because i'm
pretty sure that's where she goes
i'm like
eighty percent sure
super bobby
that's a thinker austin
when it when it says flowing blade
that doesn't necessarily mean that but
they do have a connection
i made a video on that
something about this place felt familiar
to me
so i decided to pay a visit
hoping to find someone here but i've
only found emptiness
perhaps
before my departure
i needed someone to say farewell to
well
never mind that
i must focus on my journey
for which i have you to thank
i must you're god damn right you do
okay i think that's it
i must focus on my journey
also is this
girl i am nowhere close to you
is this dog like different from the
other ones like this one has like
collars and stuff
interesting
i didn't even hit you did i
bonk
like i wonder how many times i kill that
guy's dog by accident
okay
let's explore some more
so we checked all the town
go back up here actually
and check it out i'm not sure where she
goes i well
i think we don't we find her
like right here
maybe we just do her quest line
we could
let's look around k a little bit more
because there's this uh pot throwing
giant over here
that i don't really check out very much
bonk
hmm
a lot of bats
it seems like a big ass area to sleep
like almost empty
what are they doing
they just burning grass
three
three
let's see he's got all these pots up
here
what a goof
oh
don't fall
oh i should be telling that to myself
now
stop it
get some help
nothing
pain i see an item over here
oh
oh i thought this was like open
rip pop boys
has anyone figured out how to get into
the big
uh pot pot boy
like you know what i'm talking about
there's that giant one
over
[Music]
i think over there
the [ __ ] is that
whoa what the [ __ ] is that
is that a death bird just walking around
oh [ __ ]
actually is
yeah i have not been able to interact
with that uh pot at all
i have never
seen a death bird walk around
without it just like spawning in
randomly
oh god
that was a bit of a stretch
these things right here i i just i
they are
crazy
now
man
i'm cool with that
[Music]
yeah it is probably dlc
okay locking onto you
is an issue
i
damn
i hate those things man
they are nuts
30k
ain't nothing to us
starlight shard
we already thought we're gone right yeah
yeah
who's who does it say still down there
alexander is still down there
really can we see him from here no
not
that'd be kind of cool though
okay i guess we should go into the tower
i'm thinking of the next place
to look for
i'm still holding strong on my theory
that this game is is just a giant dream
on
get out wizard
wizarded
you're trash
because kale is like a [ __ ] nightmare
in my eyes
and this dragon up here
i don't know too much about actually
the giants up there
like this dragon is omega big
omega big dragon
we actually better [ __ ] run bro
75k runes yes
um
but
to level up at this point we need 405
000
so it's uh
not
not super worth it to us
let's go get a somber eight and a somber
nine real quick
smithing stones
excuse me dragons
excuse me
okay here's our eight
so i do need a nine
boom there's an eight
and we got a nine right at the bottom of
here
owie
i don't think i die if i go straight
down but i'm just not going to
all right got a leaf
somber 9
rune arc
some dragon grease
now i think i can upgrade my sword one
more time because i now have a nine and
then i would just need an ancient
i'm pretty sure let's go back to the
round table
jen
jin streams at the same time i do most
of the time
yeah my my next video idea is actually
on the round table
so we're gonna i'm gonna be working on
that later today
lay out your arms and
i don't have enough runes for once
kidding me bro
are you kidding me
i think i need more than that
i didn't really read
uh
this yeah
why not
back already
need a five
smithing five six of them that's kind of
hard to find
uh
let's do that what does that take us to
definitely stronger
oh there we
go boom plus 10
plus 10 sword
easy
sophia still in here
yeah i gotta talk to her already okay
back to kalid
because we we got pop boy over here
um
that's that finger reader
merchant
that's where i died
already did radon
[Music]
[Laughter]
lenny's rise
i don't think i've ever been able to
open this
i also don't know who lenny is
oh we should check on uh
yeah wait who's this
is that random ass wizard
you're a wizard harry
we should check on this up
because ronnie should be gone
and i need to
talk to selvius
selva celius however you say his name
it's a lot lower than i thought
[Music]
that still hurt bro
that's not the one i was going for
oh
um
he's dead as [ __ ]
his bell bearing and all of his clothes
huh
examine
ooh
finger mated
maiden
firolina puppet one of salvia's puppets
used to summon the spirit of the finger
maiden therolina
oh that's that that's that chick that
helps us with um radon
spirit of finger maiden
who never met the tarnish she was meant
to guide
who
uses healing incantations and holy water
pots
but she is not a fighter by nature and
is ill-suited to battle maiden without a
tarnish a tarnish without a maiden and
yet no guide to bring them together ooh
what the jar wit
puppet
one of celibi's puppets uses some of the
spirit of a jar what white wheat
whatever spirit of a man who wished to
become the innards of a living jar why
a char hurtling specialist who throws
all manner of pots and jars the warrior
jar
once
told the nameless man this
you are not yet ready to join the
warriors inside no you must apply
yourself better yourself and one day i
will return for you
neat
that's really cool
is he dead
off near
made him drink the juice awesome he got
but i have the juice
i am the juicer
it's right here
i'm the juicer
interesting okay
um not wait where do we go now for uh
ronnie's questline if she's gone
cuz she she left we go talk to eg
i suppose
i forget where we go after we we do that
i'm spacing i also need to pee a little
bit
i've been drinking a gallon of water a
day chat and it's been kind of rough
with the uh the peen situation
my bladder's like the [ __ ] is all this
where is ronnie
has departed on her journey
along the dark path of imperium
from rana's rise right right right as
she calls it would her doll be where i
think it is
i pray that you serve her well
unto them oh i will i promise
what can i buy from you
ones and twos
not needed
can't strengthen anything all right i'm
gonna go pee real quick chat
i'll be right back prophecy thank you
brb brb
wow
okay
yeah i think we do go to the underground
city
which we've been to
we got to go to that
yeah
secret area
let's do it
oh the wi-fi died
um that's not good
we're still on
because i'm plugged in but the wi-fi is
being super weird lately
[Music]
ignore me
continue to sing
[Music]
there's a radagon's wolf oh god
we might as well go at it man
whoa
that's a new one
oh god
nice
easy peasy
oops
where you going where are you going
oops
also i i forgot to ask hopefully
well
i i did uh some
i made some changes to the settings
for obs streaming
it should look a little better than
usual hopefully it looks good
[Music]
i always check afterward and i'm like
should look a little better
[Music]
i know these spires have nothing to do
with ronnie but might as well do them
one
i guess we can go fight the deer
i think i have one more
yep
right over her
oh i lit that one
uh
is it the one just right at the
beginning
yep the easiest one
it is very catchy
i just i
i catch myself going
that is the only like
you know it doesn't change at all it's
just that uh
just that part
i wonder what it's for
like is it for the deer
also is this where we fight
astral
i haven't thought of that
it could be
okay i'm ready
no it's not
little early
ow
this is um one of my favorite fights in
the game
just for the way it looks
and the music in this fight is gorgeous
i love this fight
he seems pretty weak to that attack
actually the heck
oh god that is killing me
[Applause]
and healing him
that hits him pretty hard
[Music]
all
[Music]
what are you smacking bro
healing again
[Music]
god so [ __ ] cool
nope stop it
there we go
god that that is so
cool
why did the squirrel die
no
oh he takes the energy from the animals
oh
now they're all dead
it's kind of sad
this is this isn't where we fight
a steal
it reminds me of it but it's not
i need to read um his remembrance
i haven't done that very much
uh excuse me
oh we have no service at all the heck is
going on
sorry sorry
yeah lake abroad we don't really know
where that takes us
so
technically could be
remembrance
yeah we need to call our internet people
because it is the wi-fi itself is
bugging pretty bad
but i'm i'm plugged in and it's fine
just the wi-fi doesn't work just weird
century link
okay
hewn into the er tree the power of its
namesake can be unlocked by the finger
reader well we know that
ancestral spirits exist as a phenomenon
beyond the purview of the earth tree
life sprouts from death as it does from
birth
such as the way of living
life sprouts from death and it does from
birth
such is the way of living
i mean that makes sense for like what it
does it takes the energy from the
animals
very interesting
is this your favorite souls game
for me yes
i think that's just because i love open
world games like red dead 2 and skyrim
are two of my other favorite games too
but um
i would say like bloodborne
is
a masterpiece of a game
and i might say the same for sakiro
i like all the dark souls games
my least favorite being dark souls 2
which is pretty typical
but this one's
this one's my favorite
absolutely
yup
what is happening with our weefy that is
so weird
have you guys played all the souls games
or is this like your first one
oh god
i think we got crucible night here yep
ow
my attack is too slow
oh god
these things suck
that didn't help very much
oh got him a little bit
there we go my god
bloodborne's still your favorite lore
yeah bloodborne's
masterpiece of the game i think this
game's a masterpiece too
yeah like a masterpiece can have
problems
because nothing's perfect but it's about
as good as it gets along with bloodborne
it's my first souls game so i don't know
much about the series i'm thinking of
buying one of the older souls games any
suggestions
all of them
that may that may seem like a [ __ ]
suggestion but i promise man like
play all the play all of them
they're all good
now dark souls 3
or dark souls 2
dark souls 3 is fantastic that was my
first one ever actually
um
all of them are good
sakiro
i would recommend bloodborne sakura dark
souls 3.
those are gonna be your best
experiences
uh after playing elden ring
who is this
do we
know i have no idea
got little centipedes
it's like no
grace around here is there
can't kill you
interesting
all right we're going to do this with no
healing at all let's go
i'll pop a mimik [ __ ] it
is that dee's brother
it sounded like him oh i do have healing
oh cool
ow
what
god these things hit for so much
as i just get blasted by it
i don't think we're gonna live through
this one
get rid of this one we have a chance
nice
pretty sure if i get one time i'm dead
so let's do this attack
that's not good
yes
jesus
i'm pretty sure if i get if i got hit by
that i i would have died
holy
yeah we're doing a lot of damage
a lot
the [ __ ] is up there
nothing
okay let's rest
and our wi-fi
says it's on and it's not
that is really weird
three bars and everything
is that where the i don't
is that where the other one drops down
from
yeah we gotta call
centurylink or something
if the stream randomly dies no it's my
internet's fault
she
you've seen one get stuck up there
that's kind of cool
so
the coffin like when it's taking us up
has those like high hieroglyphics
in the
kind of like spell that takes you up
there that reminds me of uh what's on my
sword actually
oh god
i forgot i have to go down one more
can you see that
kind of
on the side of the sword
isn't there a avatar up here yep
now
actually yeah
no idea how i'm alive
oh my god i suck
there we go
arcane magic
um potentially
staff of the avatar
i have to have that already
[Laughter]
yeah i have three of them
ceremonial staff depicting the earth
tree and it's historic radiance wielded
by the avatars who protect the minor
trees the avatars emerging in the wake
of the elden ring shattering were
determined to protect the witherings
withering er trees offspring
okay
i mean yeah we see the we see those guys
at every minor her tree so they're just
there to protect them that's kind of
cool
i read somewhere that there's like a
um
a
relation with god
godwin
and the minor urgery avatars
because they kind of sprout
like like he does
he's like right up here
[Music]
god this is another area we gotta check
out i just wanna do ronnie's questline
i don't know about you guys but i just
run the [ __ ] through here every time
got a lot of ants
we're way down in the roots
way down
hello
such
lord
such humiliation
oh my poor sweet lordly
should have died a true death
as the first of the demigods to die
as a martyr
to destined death
but why the city hat brings such
disgrace
a sign of the golden bomb
sentenced to live
in death
man i have not heard that dialogue
before or if i have i didn't understand
it at the time that's crazy
same thing
because we know he was the first to die
and he's technically
still alive
just in body not in spirit
bonk
i thought that was an elevator for a
second
that's a good way to put that evan a
tumor
very solid comparison
kind of is a tumor
i don't think fia is gonna be here
because i haven't um
i don't think i've asked her about the
dagger yet
is this just gonna be an open area
is that we know that's a god win now
so [ __ ] creepy man
what is this
yeah that's godwin
technically alive
but not really
oh our champions do appear
are you alive
how do you become fish squid man
uh he was
he is infected
or not infected
he was stabbed by the rune of death
the
the um
struggling to say right now
he was stabbed with the rune of death on
the night of the black knives
and he was killed in spirit where ronnie
was killed in
body
so he's technically alive
kinda
just in spirit
love you too kyle
oh god
what what's this guy doing over here man
to come and play
huh
what you doing
any spells hello
apparently not all right
work lame facts
that damage is [ __ ] insane
leave me alone
okay dude
yee
dang
[Music]
there we go
yeah if he is not here
that will take me to the capital city
i'm like
99 sure
well
i guess it
let's go to fia
let's talk to her about
the uh
the dagger she wants us to give to
d nuts right there
hey look at that wi-fi is back what
happens to the wi-fi bro
what happens to you
that's quite scaly
uh
i killed your companions to see you
again
would you like me to hold you
what the blessing would you like
yes
come closer hold me mommy
please
please
hold me
oh
you are so
very warm
about the dagger
of the dagger i gave you oh she already
didn't return it to them it's a very
precious thing
it must have a special place
got it
is it a key item
um
it would be called a dagger
i think
let's give it to him
hey
it's trey
let's go
thanks for the membership man
you're my first member let's go
thank you dude
you're now an investor
these nuts
thank you trey
first member
we got badges baby
i got those um this morning
their number
unless you wish to lay down your life in
vain
uh
with a sure for weed in death root
how would you like to earn the strength
of beasts
if you're inclined to haunt more of
those who live in death and weed their
death root i want five percent of your
massive preacher earnings
all right well
yeah i'll settle for point five
interesting
i have not heard him say this before
no i know you're kidding thank you man i
i appreciate it
and you get a green name
very well
oh so he just tells us
yeah
we've already been there
that's what i figured it was
i want to give you the doggy
taxes is always
amazing
no i did not
okay so now we can rest
hey glenn how we doing man
well you have a good day trey thank you
for the for the membership dude
thank you
okay
did i rest
yeah he's gone
fee is gone
and this door should be open yup
got it
she's gonna be like i'm
evil
[Music]
i don't think she's evil finally
it is returned to its rightful place
the stolen hallow brand
of the exalted noble god damn she [ __ ]
him
i ask you up this message
to the round table hold
i am fear
deathbed companion we already knew this
there should be a join button
and it will give you all the options
what right does anyone have to object
our lord will rise
the lord of the many
and the meek
she talking about
god
i when so
okay we got his bell
and his armor
so those are the twin greaves
might as well do this
uh
this quest line now since we're pretty
much done with it and then we can go do
ronnie's quest line
i have yet to figure out what the [ __ ]
to do with this guy i've decided
i need i need to look that up
give assassins prayer book i'm pretty
sure he gives it away
it's a good idea triplets
uh
it's bulkins blessing is um
is it a talisman
no
does he have a good questline i have not
i haven't messed with him at all
my whole first playthrough i was like
where's where's gold mask
must be first tab
tools thank you
so we got the radiant
protection of the hidden temple in the
guise of the bed chamber this blessing
is of the utmost rarity
uses fp to temporarily raise poise the
effect lasts longer than a mere favor
which is this got it
it's said a deathbed companion will only
produce a blessing of this kind
for a champion but once in her entire
life
the soul blessing which she imbues of
her own volition
damn
so we got that i mean [ __ ] okay
the favor allows one to forget any aches
and pains in death there is only peace
for in death there can be no
sin
sensation
[Music]
you find them at altis junction when
they all leave the round table got it
okay
i think i have that unlocked
hi it's you nefeli hello
i've not seen you here before huh
the pleasure's mine how is she just
coming up what guided by grace to the
round table hold
on we talk more i wonder if you've met
my study if you haven't already father
is unsure
guys do i give her the potion
selvis is dead
um
[ __ ] it
is that some kind of medicine yeah just
drink it
if it's what i think
i have no need of it i am a warrior i
need no external aid damn
the horrors of battle
not to bolster my resolve
so she's like pogba's huh
okay i know where she goes now
okay
also what triggers her
to fight me in the round table
because i've had that happen a couple
times and i'm just like huh
you've received the wisdom of the two
fingers have you not
yes
as a true member of the round table
i am known as gideon of
i am accumulating knowledge
to be
all knowing
you now belong to a select group of
fellows
as such
i ask that you remain constant
you'll be after more great rooms now eh
then as your fellow allow me to divulge
a little knowledge
the inheritors of the great runes the
shah bearers
we of the round table know the location
of five of them
including the one you defeated
godric the grafted lord of stormvale
general radha
who fought melania and her rot to a
standstill in the caled wilds
prater reichard
lord of the volcano manor of mount
gilmere
moore got the grace given
getting the first half the medallion
okay thank you thank you
interesting
i understand you've been speaking why
doesn't she want us to find
the holiday
or he i think
her he's credulity suited mine i'm not
sure
so i put it to work
do not hesitate to employ her
should her services benefit you despite
her looks
she is more than capable i'm not seeing
the join button
uh
a trey found
go to the description it should say
become a member as well it should be
right next to the subscribe button
like right next to it
okay i won't grab it yet
you calm down lady
you guys notice these pictures right
here too
that's gotta be queen america with the
red hair
i've yet to find that out that is that
would be the question what
i guess we could read her armor
because i've got her armor she killed
her twice elm grace with gold human
bones warned by the unspeaking adherent
of sir gideon of all the all-knowing it
said that the bones belonged to an
ancient lord the soulless king the lord
of the lost and desperate who was known
as encha
you see i don't know much about incha
also her weapon
is
where
it's like a bone
there it is jesus horrific weapon made
of hardening
hardened skeletal arm wielded by incha
of the royal remains fitted by placing
one's hand into the fist grips until
they dig in
oh clinging creature a king relinquishes
not the hand
skill that demonstrates mastery of the
art of controlling vital energies a slow
controlled punch
interesting
doesn't seem like it tells us anything
yeah i saw that too triplets
i think gideon puts a hit on you oh
well he does apologize
after because you kill her and then if
you talk to him he apologizes
not saying that he sent her off on you
but that it happened at all
because isn't it isn't this supposed to
be like a place that no one's supposed
to like fight or something
who knows let's go back underground
[Music]
there she is
hello
there you are
i knew you would come
what is it you intend
to deny us and our ways
like the dogmatic brutes of the golden
order
nope i just want to be held
yes please i love hugs
it's my one weakness i love hugs
talk in
a hallow secret
when the first of the demigods died his
flesh was marked with the half-wheel
wound of the centipede
godwin's hallow brand has since been
recovered at the round table hold
but there is another hello brand out
there somewhere
and i must find it
before the time comes we receive our
lord
now i've done your questline before
and i must find it
before the time comes we receive our
lord
my hands will be dirtied once more by
the deed
will you still let me hold you
even then i mean you could wash your
hands
give curse mark of death
there it is
with this
godwin can take his rightful place as
first i think a lot of people kill her
when they realize that she does a debuff
to your health
how bad it smells here bro this entire
area looks like what you would see at
the bottom of a porta potty
okay we already have that
talking secret
with godwin
i'm sure he
will first dead of the demigods
as the rune of those who live in death
please
do one thing for me
brandish this child
my room
and take for yourself the throne
stay the persecution of those who live
in death
by becoming
our elden lord
it's 100 god one
that's like
that's why she's here
i think that's it
okay
and then i can rest and she should be
asleep
kind of sad god would end it up here
yeah um
yeah i mean ronnie
maybe that was the deal she had to make
with the black knife assassins
where they had to kill godwin if they
were going to um
also slay her own imperial flesh
because i guess there has to be a
trade-off
because this this is godwin it's
confirmed like that's that's him he's
just turned into this gross [ __ ]
freak
you can even see his bracelet right
there
how come you can see his face in her
stormbill castle well okay so think
about it he's um
he's at the roots of the earth tree
right he's this that's where we are it's
called the roots of the earth tree
there's all these roots around
everywhere he's infecting the roots
and the sprout like that's why you can
see his face like at the top underneath
stormville castle it's spread all the
way up there and kind of creates this
weird looking like shell thing like
right under his nose here
so he can create like little masks
himself i like to think he can move
between
the ones because technically he's alive
he's just dead in spirit he's just his
gross [ __ ] body
um
he can't do anything
yeah exactly like a tumor
exactly
but that's why he's infecting the er
tree
slowly but surely
she asleep
no
past time
nightfall
still not asleep do i have to come back
i forget what triggers her to go to
sleep
she say something different now
all right i think i have to talk to her
again actually
wait i just go right into being held
there ain't no other option
okay
my question is how the hell is she gonna
have sex with godwin
there we go
greater blessing could there be
but to be born a deathbed companion
um
a lot of a lot of things could be better
a lot
maybe not to you
okay now she should go to sleep
we gotta get that tree sap
get pregnant from the tree sap so she
can bear a child
okay now she's asleep
they just gotta try hard i mean
whoa can't imagine
a lot of people thought she was dead but
she's clearly like moving like asleep
chad you guys into toes
okay sorry
okay that's cool
all right for the saks
oh god i didn't realize there was so
much mist
whoa
chill chill chill
oops
okay
this ain't gonna reach
okay it kinda did
i unfortunately wasted
my
wondrous flask
where you going dog
that is [ __ ] awesome
music's really cool too
okay doki buddy
dang that frost
dude frostbite is like the most powerful
thing in this game
like uh uh effect you can do
yo there you go you found it glenn
and became an
investor that's the tier above the
member one so thank you man
we got two investors
thank you glenn i appreciate it man
is she dead here
uh
yeah
yeah
she ain't moving at all
rip or she might not be dead dead
manny rune of the great prince
mommy
mommy
mama
mama
okay
so i think if we rest and come back
dee's brother is here
oh now we have an item actually
oh you get her close
at least for me he was here
hmm
what's past time like to noon or
something
but thank you glenn
appreciate it man
nope
all right
let's travel and come back
oh mobile
i always forget about mobile dude
but yeah you can just go to the
description i always have it in there
man i love getting notifications that i
paid my credit card bill that's
fantastic i love hearing that
i guess that is a good thing
she died doing what she loved
getting banged
a little bit too hard this time
i just want to check this out really
quick
okay let's go back
look at that we were right below
directly below
the
prince of death's throne
interesting
still not here i wonder what triggers
that
is her body is still rocking it
is he at the round table well he can't
be at the round table
because he's dead
yep
no longer alive my guy all right
um
let's go back across and we'll go find
the doll that's what we want
did you give his armor set to his
brother ah
there it is
that was
over
[Music]
here
and then across hopefully he's still
there
because i don't i didn't have his armor
set when i met him when i went this way
so he could still be there
so this this is dee's brother i wasn't
entirely sure
got it does he we don't doesn't look
anything like him
then again we don't know what d looks
like because he has all that armor on
that's why we give him the set
makes sense
thank you thank you
yeah looks like we're still here
you know
hand over twin armor
set up
no you didn't ruin it i i just wasn't
entirely sure
so thank you
okay now
let's go back
and he'll be like
yep
the wrath of the golden order the orders
justice writ in blood
this is what's become of your precious
witch
naught but expired meat and bone this is
a proper death oh prince
look at this rotten hall
no more children can be got from this
useless flesh
behold
your mother is dead
mother
this is revenge you witch and you you
cool
this is the wrath of d
twin brother
hello hi the rotten witch is dead
the wicked witch is dead
[Music]
now i have no regrets
honeyed rays of gold
deliver my spirit
darian
called her a [ __ ]
straight up
like god damn man all right
well that's not my business i suppose
do we know where we can find him
what do we get here
you take off all his clothes like the
[ __ ] okay
interesting
okay let's let's actually go
interesting
ah
oh hello oh my controller's spazzed
controller
none of my buttons are working oh god
except
except
walking
huh oh god
how did walking work and literally
nothing else
what
i can't even pause
whoa
interesting glitch if it is a glitch
that was random too like i didn't unplug
my controller or anything it just like
stopped working
there we go
well the analog
or the d-pad worked
x button nothing
hello
i can use the d-pad
but
the buttons don't work
i wonder if um the game had its update
because it said it was gonna have an
update for uh pvp stuff
i think
hello
[Music]
hey yo
man
jesus that took forever too
yup
i think it just updated
okay up to date
3 55 a.m
i don't know
i don't know what just happened
that was random because i i did not
unplug the controller at all
it was just like randomly like
we're gonna start plugging
we're bugging [ __ ]
[Music]
some guy commented on my reading
negative elden ring steam reviews video
vincent
says you can say anything you want but
this game is overrated as [ __ ]
thoughts chat
okay the a button worked there
all right we're back
we're back
yep
also his profile picture is that of a
monkey
an orangutan actually
okay that was weird
we move on and conquer though
dead
way to stun walk that man
vincent got scrambled egg brain
i agree
game has flaws but it's a masterpiece i
agree
everything has flaws
you can look past flaws if it's good
enough and this game is clearly good
enough
there's so much good it offsets the bad
wag
this game overrated as [ __ ]
man
look at all these coffins
then our coffin
um
oh glenn you guys playing um
you know actually i already knew that
you said that yesterday that you're
playing us hero right
hell yeah good ass game
and bloodborne you had to use your
your girls ps4 though yeah
like listen i gotta take away the ps4 i
am uh
i gotta play bloodborne
hell yeah dude
sweet
have you started either one yet
okay
bloodborne at night perfect
ronnie's doll should be right here
miniature
runny
i wonder if i can read a description on
that doll resembling ronnie the witch
from head to toe every detail is perfect
this unresponsive doll seems pleasantly
cool
ronnie do be pretty cool
started both enjoying both good to hear
dude
both are fantastic in their own ways
talk to miniature ronnie
nothing
nothing
oh there we go
aren't we
or is it merely thy habit to talk to
dolls
fine
fine
i hadn't expected any soul to recognize
me in this guise
but now the cat is out the bag
i cannot allow thee thy freedoms
perform for me as service as recompense
eliminate the baleful shadows which
prowl these lands
the name of rani the witch is already
sullied by thee so she's like pissed at
blight
disobedience in this matter
i will not broke disobedience in this
manner perform for me as service as
recompense
eliminate the bale of the name of ronnie
the witches i will not
she is a pissed
is ronnie ever not angry
it's more like me walking up to her and
saying bloodborne
then downloading it and playing
what games does your girl play
come here boy give me that head
give me that noggin
there we go
man
hanging a cap those things scare the
[ __ ] out of me chat
she only plays cod interesting
which one
like warzone
no way
oh she's toxic huh hell yeah
found a gamer
i ain't gonna spend too much time on
these ants
there we go
search and destroy modern warfare huh
damn
nice
it is low crafty and that weird ass
astual
the hell is this
the [ __ ]
oh i don't like that
not one bit
you
the wicked witch not stuck in my head
definitely don't need that
man another area we should explore but
let's just get randy's thing done
bugs are disgusting couldn't agree more
i don't [ __ ] around with bugs i don't
like bugs
ever
any bug
nope
don't like it
in real life in games anywhere any bug
don't like him
not a fan
oh god
oh god
when in doubt
roll
roll your ass off
go over here though
leave me alone thank you
thank you very much
we should have find
blight down here
which is blight just here to stop us
because he's jealous that we're getting
it done and he's not
if so that's pretty sussy baka
i think that's a glove 9 right there
i don't think it's blight i mean it's a
shadow of blight
or a baleful shadow
eat it
[ __ ]
how much health does he have
there's a lot of health
he is a resistant
to like cold
i like how her voice like trails off
like she's leaving
because she's just a spirit and can and
can just do that
but where does that shadow come from
also i should read this key too
discarded palace ski
uh discarded by illinois ronnie
alongside her very flesh opens his
treasure chest passed down to the caring
princess can be found inside the grand
library so it just tells you where it is
okay
okay
okay
badass
you hit this
talk about an area i have not checked
out like at all
because uh
it's gross
let's go to the library
thank you sean
welcome welcome
i don't know how delayed those are
but thank you
punishes you so hard for not being aggro
well
uh yeah you either have to deflect like
they're dodging in sakiro is pretty much
like it's useful in some ways but
you know how you like roll in this game
you don't do that in skiro you deflect
you're you're a sore master swordsman
there's there's a point to it you know
okay
got her ring
have i read the
it's gotta be a
key yep
rain depicting a
leading full moon
symbolic of a cold oath
the ring is supposed to be given by
lunar princess ronnie to her consort
ronnie is an empyrean meaning her
consort would by rights earn the title
of lord
a warning is engraved within whoever
thou mayest be take not the ring from
this place
the solitude beyond the night is better
mine alone
so she doesn't want us to do it
interesting
how'd you write all that on a ring
still insane okay
it's cool we're like right below that
area too
they even thought of like where the
underground area should be
in accordance to like the above ground
areas it's so cool
[Music]
okay we want that
yeah sakiro is all about deflection
deflecting
[Music]
aren't he's supposed to there we go
just to make it like a little better
and we just
run
we're pretty strong
that's kind of pointless
let's heal until i can leave
[Music]
let's try this one out i don't think
i've ever hit this checkpoint right here
also is there somewhere i can walk up
there it looks like
yep
never been over here
it's not even an item
there's that dragon dude
i think i can
[ __ ] off
jeez
i wonder who the like this is
all right
weird i can walk up here and there's
just nothing
interesting
no torrent either
i guess that's just another way to get
up here is that there's a ladder
um okay
and thrusting
oh we're gaming out here right now
we are gaming oh
can't fully avoid it
go
[Music]
nice
[Music]
ambient music in this game is [ __ ]
incredible
let's see
can probably finish the randy quest line
and then i'll be done for today
and then i will be back on wednesday
i wasn't even supposed to be live today
but i didn't stream yesterday i had some
stuff going on so i thought i'll make up
for it by streaming today
why not
oh
okay i'll take it i'll take it
actually we want to drop down into this
crack
yep
centipede
the
i heck i've been this way
hmm
good reason there ain't [ __ ]
not
what i thought i had equipped
die
break these things man
okay the sword is really good
against those guys
a lot of rooney boys down here
i believe we get the dagger of some kind
in there oh my god that statue is
[ __ ] huge
this guy seemed to praise him
let's get it
yeah we can probably do this part and
then um
we'll be back on wednesday
does this one just fall like is there
any rune magic going on here at all no
it just
it just goes straight down
nice nice nice
which again this this area reminds me so
much of where we fight the um
regal ancestor spirit the the moose boss
or deer boss i think it's a moose
[Music]
yeah yeah
well the plan for today was to explore
caled but we just wound up doing like uh
two quest lines pretty much
probably yeah
it happens
welcome to elden ring
you get lost in the sauce
all right mimic
on
go with that
i wonder
can this thing even freeze
what
what
this thing is spamming
oh god that almost killed me
meteor
i kind of messed them up
oh god that's
i'm dead too bro oh my god that scared
the [ __ ] out of me
holy [ __ ] that was actually scary all
right this time i'm just going to smack
him with my sword i think it'll do even
better
i do oh
no my window is not open while i'm
streaming
it's sand like right in the middle
[Music]
[Music]
okay i was kind of whiff on his part
my head
oh god
nah didn't hurt that bad oh god
can you let me heal
thank you
i keep forgetting to
bam
that comes out of nowhere
[Music]
dang i remember one-shotting this boss
like first try
i 100 closed it okay sorry
okay mimic coming back in
immediately attacks you got it
i'm gonna get a little bit closer
let me hit him with this
that was bad
[Applause]
yep that's my fault again
i'm trying to like cheese this guy when
i just shouldn't
[Music]
sorry i'm getting texts
all right this is the one 100
shoot me first
did i pick up my runes from before
nope
no idea how many we lost
i can't stop cheesing
okay
not even a cheese
nice
there we go
hello video game okay
just didn't work
that sucks
i wasn't sure if he was going to grab me
dang i was already down he hit me that
hard
now
[Music]
oh
okay dude
did they like buff this guy
what
okay
one more
oh
dude i freaking knew it too oh god
the heck was that i've never seen that
come on
what
okay
jeez
geez that was way harder than
i guess it is like new game plus four so
it's gonna be hard
that was like way harder than usual
see isn't i guess this place is
different from the
regal spirit
just couldn't see it till now
[Music]
i'm calling randy
oh
it's like showing day time for a second
and then just switch to
like the moonlight effect it does here
all right let's kill this dragon
okay
all right are you just like impervious
to freeze like what's going on here
wait i didn't want to do that yet
okay now i want to do it
well
going for it
i'm like locked onto a squirrel
go for it
badass
the head is also hitting you there
that's cool
and by cool i mean
kind of dumb
monk
mimic going crazy with it let's go
nice
oh no
don't kill me nice
oh okay
i see i see
no idea where i was gonna go
going for it
there we go
nice
you get the moon blade from him that's
probably why he was like
he did not take any damage
to like frost at all
i thought he was like a magic
which i guess is frost so that makes
sense
[Music]
all right
let's go do the end of ronnie's
questline and then we'll be done for
today
we
i think the
like atmosphere in this little room is
so cool
creepy
slaughtered the two fingers down here
welcome back trey
still has your eyes closed in this
cutscene too around one side
god i want to see like what happened
there because we see what like the
aftermath of it but i want to see what
happened
hi so it was thee
who would become my lord
perhaps i needn't have warned thee
i am pleased however
it is there i shall find mine order
i bid thee
travel the path of the lord
i will
we shall see each other
once more
no longer maidenless boys let's go
nice we already have that like three
times over
all right guys
that is gonna do it for me today
we'll be back on wednesday
noon just like we always do
uh with probably some more lore hunting
i also want to do a uh i want to try and
beat this game using only a torch that
because you can upgrade the torch and
everything that could be kind of fun
that could be a fun challenge run that
we do there's all kinds of challenge
runs that we could do that would be
pretty fun but
we'll see what happens on wednesday have
a great rest of your day thank you for
watching thank you for the support
appreciate the the new memberships today
from trey and glenn
appreciate it guys
um but yeah we'll be back on wednesday
look out for a new video coming out
um probably either tomorrow or on
wednesday before stream
uh about the round table so hopefully
enjoy that give it a watch join our
discord follow me on twitter all that
good stuff
i'll see you guys soon see you on
wednesday guys
bye